[Musik]
alles noch nicht gelernt haben das ganze
theoretische rüstzeug kann ich in der
schweiz gelernt und arbeitsmoral will
ich in die schweiz
viele leute aber mitgeholfen und viele
leute aber auch an beigebracht immer
steif und mein wissen und das
hinbekommen habe weitergeben
marian all-in und edin salkic machten
ihre erfahrungen in der schweiz
sie trugen das erworbene wissen nach
bosnien und rumänien wo sie hunderte von
arbeitsplätze geschaffen haben
ich möchte herausfinden was hinter
diesem großen erfolg steht
[Musik]
unternehmerisch tätig sie dass ich so
einen traum vom lag sie immer weniger
wirtschaft für die er aber viel mehr
unternehmer zieht man da kommentar
gegründet damals 22 jährige student war
also verfehle ja sie zwei kommunikations
städte einnehmen was die herzegowina und
1 in serbien
es sind möbelproduzenten beide firma in
bauschheim rund 400 angestellte ins rw
rund 300 angestellte und weise
produziert möbel für die klatsch kam
1974 als fünfjähriger mit seinen eltern
in die schweiz
sein vater ist zahnarzt er stammt aus
montenegro
die mutter war sozialwissenschaftlerin
aus serbien
er studiert an der hochschule st gallen
internationale beziehungen mit
schwerpunkt wirtschaft den ist
verheiratet und hat zwei kinder im
schulalter
[Musik]
mit seiner firma da kommt ist edin dacic
seit über zwei jahrzehnten auf dem
balkan geschäftlich erfolgreich
drei bis vier tage in der woche
verbringt er in seinen
produktionsstätten
ich begleite ihn auf eine reise zu
seiner möbelfabrik in bosnien
[Musik]
ich bin aufgewachsen in der schweiz
tätig skizwerge schlosses land sind alle
länder noch kein globalisierten ökonomie
groß dass ich alles sehr viel erklärt
hat was es braucht zumindest eine
karriere zu machen
der abschluss haben ein militär aus
vernehmungen ich mir schon offizier sie
unter + müsse mit der befürchtung dass
wir nach einem eher günstige position
wird verwehrt bliebe das allein schon
akzeptabel für mich ich habe da
geschäftliche möglichkeit sehe das mit
relativ wenig kapital
ein hoch erreicht der blick schon
bestanden und nach der tragödie
neunziger jahre hat sie natürlich ein
vierzylinder der welt in kauf als
sicherheit die wenn man sie verkauft
hätte organisiert zu kaufen
[Musik]
dieser messe
wie komme ich gar nicht
[Musik]
die bosnische hauptstadt sarajevo war
schon immer eine kosmopolitische stadt
viele religionen leben hier
nebeneinander in nächster nähe befinden
sich kirchen synagogen und moscheen
der gnadenlose krieg in den 90er jahren
zerstörte das friedliche zusammenleben
heute zieht die stadt wieder touristen
aus den nachbarländern aber auch aus
übersee
[Musik]
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung des
landes kommt nur langsam voran
[Musik]
die entwicklung ist schon gang und
machen nichts passiert investiert wurde
aber es ist viel zu wenig passiert das
feld der politische stabilität ohne
politische stabilität raska
wirtschaftliche stabilität und die
wirtschaftliche stabilität flüsse drei
investition aus russland und natürlich
viel zu wenig
[Musik]
geschafft der fabrik der firma da kommt
sie zu dem jahr 2004
da kommen mehrheit von derstandard.at
immer noch am anfang sind 84 prozent
um die top 100 prozent hier in prüm
niveau produziert die fabrik standard
auf mehr als 10.000 quadratmetern möbel
102 artikel werden für ikea hergestellt
die weltweit vertrieben werden
die belegschaft kommt aus den dörfern
der umgebung der lohn eines arbeiters
rund 400 euro liegt zwar im durchschnitt
der branche in bosnien
trotzdem ist er um einiges tiefer als
der lohn eines arbeiters in westeuropa
[Musik]
die firma richard desolate zustand
ziehen
die firma nur überlebt weil sie bei
einem projekt zum beispiel sehr
produziert sind
es ist nur ums buch über lehrgang der
generaldirektor wo schon in sozialismus
generaldirektors ist er mit der hand
voll mitarbeiter hat dafür gesorgt dass
die firma nicht ausgeraubt wurde ich mit
geplündert oder ich will dass die ganze
woche
zum ritter guten morgen ich möchte diese
sitzung mit der skype konferenz von
letzter woche beginnen bei nicht alle
teilgenommen hat deshalb möchte ich sie
bitten uns kurz zu sagen was im moment
für lieferungen anstehen
wie sind die entwicklungen und die
prognosen für die nächsten wochen
die arbeitswoche von engeln dacic
beginnt mit der sitzung mit seinen
abteilungsleiterinnen und
abteilungsleitern sie berichten ihm über
den aktuellen stand der produktion die
auftragsbücher scheinen zufrieden
stellen zu sein
das geschäft läuft boro jewgeni ist
schon seit über 30 jahren general
direktor der fabrik
nach dem krieg stand sie vor dem aus
ohne das engagement von edin terzic
hätte die fabrik nicht überlebt sagt er
zu beginn der zusammenarbeit mit intouch
finanzierte er nur die produktion der
ware
ideen gab den kredit und zahlte die
differenz für die arbeit sobald die ware
über den fluss sawa ging also über die
grenze ausgeliefert wurde
eine zeit lang haben wir so produziert
und nach der zollabwicklung hat er uns
bezahlt und so lief das und mit der zeit
haben die sein vertrauen gewonnen und
das war auf einmal einiges möglich
ich frage projekt etwas genauer die
touch mit seiner firma da kommt hierher
gebracht hat investitionskapital als
flüssige mittel ohne das hätten wir die
normale produktion gar nicht sagen
können eine gewisse sicherheit für die
handlungsfähigkeit von standard
das anders
drittens investitionen welche mit
nachdruck die kapazitäten gesteigert
haben
diese drei punkte statt
es ist der vierte
er ist und bleibt ein schweizer bürger
damit ist alles gesagt
mit ihm ist auch das vertrauen des
abnehmers gekommen
er hat immer sein wort gehalten und dann
für jede abmachung ein und die
produktion wuchs von monat zu monat
wir haben sehr großen fortschritt
gemacht wir haben zwei millionen euro
investiert wir sind quasi vor seiner für
friedhof 400 mir wachsen twitter was mir
aber meist der hoffnung geht sind liegt
die firma standard hat mir einen job
gegeben obwohl ich gerade erst von der
hochschule kam ich war noch sehr
unerfahren aber die firma hat in mich
investiert auch in meine weiterbildung
so dass sich der firma etwas zurückgeben
kann die wirtschaft sich schon abteilung
leitet und mit ende 20 shows führen die
direktorin
wenn ich die arbeit bei standard nicht
hätte wäre ich heute nicht in brehna war
mein job ist der einzige grund warum ich
hier in meinem heimatort leben bestimmt
wäre ich wie andere leute aus meiner
generation die keine arbeit in ihrem
beruf gefunden haben ins ausland
gegangen
vielleicht hätte ich einen job auf einem
kreuzfahrtschiff angenommen um die welt
zu sehen fremdsprachen zu lernen und um
geld zu verdienen
ja ich bin die einzige frau im top
management der firma ich muss sagen dass
ich gar keine schlechten erfahrungen
dabei gemacht habe ich werde von allen
kollegen respektiert auch deshalb weil
mich der inhaber der firma respektiert
er respektiert alle gleichermaßen egal
ob frau oder mann er sieht alle menschen
gleich und achtet ihre aufgaben im
unternehmen
[Musik]
standard ist der arbeitgeber nummer eins
in brehna war
400 leute arbeiten hier und versorgen
ihre familien von diesem einkommen
die leute sind sehr zufrieden mit ihrem
arbeitgeber
zum einen weil der eigentümer ein
schweizer ist das gibt schon eine
sicherheit
es lässt die leute mit zuversicht in die
zukunft schauen
zum anderen ist wie er die nummer eins
auf dem globalen möbelmarkt
hauptabnehmer der firma das alles gibt
den leuten ein gutes gefühl und einen
sicheren arbeitsplatz
[Musik]
die stadt sibiu in der region
siebenbürgen in rumänien
[Musik]
hier wurde marian aline geboren auch
ihre erfolgsgeschichte hat ihren anfang
in der schweiz genommen
nach dem zusammenbruch des
sozialistischen systems suchte die
gelernte krankenschwester 1995 in
münchen arbeitet dort lernte sie auch
ihren früheren mann kennen mit dem sie
sich später in der schweiz niederließ
marianne bildete sich zur
betriebswirtschaftlerin weiter und
arbeitete als finanz controllerin bei
einem großen technologiekonzern im
kanton bern
ich habe ihm werden im emmental gewohnt
auf dem land in niederwenigern genauer
wie man kennt der mental ist eine region
mit mit vielen käsereien und so langsam
kam
[Musik]
vielleicht hätten eine kleine käserei
rumänien aufzubauen
so habe ich angefangen er das wochenende
in verschiedenen käsereien zu arbeiten
immer um drei oder vier in die nacht
arbeiten gegangen einfach um die
prozesse zu kennen zu lernen und zu
sehen ob überhaupt was werde
und dann finden käserei besitzer habe
ich es selbst gut sehen können
die alleinerziehende mutter eines
achtjährigen sohnes ist gründerin der
firma car parat die inzwischen drei
geschäftszweige betreibt eine molkerei
eine konti 3 und 10 cafés marianne
beschäftigt rund 75 angestellte davon
über 80 prozent frauen
ich wollte mich auch die fachkundigen
was die produktion von milchprodukten
sein sollte
und die habe in zollikofen ein kurs
besucht technisches und wirtschaftliches
über bäckereien ländern können in der
mozartschule in zollikofen wurde marie
annalynne große hilfsbereitschaft
entgegen gebracht als sie von ihrem
traum einer eigenen morgen rumänien
erzählte sie haben sich so gefreut über
mein projekt sie wollten nicht mal das
geld den kurs zu nehmen
sie haben mir sehr viel material
mitgegeben bücher und sie haben mir
alles gute für die zukunft gewünscht
sie erhielt vom staatssekretariat für
wirtschaft seco einen kredit und mit
ihren eigenen ersparnissen war der staat
kapital gesichert
maria anna leenen kaufte 2003 hier die
stillgelegte kolchose mit drei hektaren
land in der einst bis zu 800 kühe
gehalten wurden
zwei jahre habe ich gebraucht um die
aktivitäten zu finden
das größte problem hat das wasser weil
auch wenn der ferienzeit die farben die
hatte kein wasser wasser führte mit ist
angebracht
für alle die quere er brachte mir gesagt
er werde nie wasser finden dort marianna
schwägerin in der schweiz hatte im
fernsehen von einem experten gehört der
überall auch in der wüste wasser findet
voller hoffnung kontaktierte sie den
mann aus dem wallis
ich kann mich erinnern noch auf der
autobahn ich habe ihnen das video
gezeigt da gesagt hat aber ein es gibt
schon was es gibt wasser auf diesem land
und ich habe mich sehr wichtig sagt nein
das ist gar nicht so eine bohrung kostet
pro meter
ich kann mir nicht leisten so
im blind zu bohren und dann ich habe ihn
gefragt ob es möglich wäre dass das
argument kommt und da gesagt ok kommen
aus rumänien wenn du nichts hin dass
bezahlung mir nichts mit habe umgebaut
und nach zwei tagen hat er gesagt wir
sollen die maschen herausnehmen es wird
wasser kommen alle die anderen leute
abgeschaut ist nicht wahr ich habe man
die idee heraus genommen und es kam
wasser
[Musik]
damit gedacht ja ich mache mein großes
projekt mit großen molkerei und gott sei
dank hat die unterstützung von 6 ich
habe beratung bekommen von ihnen und sie
haben wir empfohlen
klein anzufangen das zu versuchen von
dem gebäude schon stehen ist können sie
zu renovieren und mit weniger kosten
etwas aufzubauen und das geschäft
starten
[Musik]
2005 im oktober
was ist dabei herausgekommen und dann
kann man auch die probleme es war sehr
schwierig von rohstoff das problem war
dass die leute aber nicht verstanden das
ist qualität sein muss da wir haben
zuerst nach fettgehalt bezahlt dann
haben wir werden immer wieder probleme
da wäre fremdes fetten gefunden haben
schweineschmalz hünerfeld drehen und
immer wieder solche praktikern und das
hat unsere ware kaputt gemacht
[Musik]
manja berlin ließ sich von den vielen
problemen die sich ihr in den weg
stellten nicht beirren
einige male konnte sie für deren lösung
auf ihre kontakte in der schweiz
zurückgreifen
die hatte produktions probleme technisch
lösen könnte und so habe ich einen
supertollen berater bekommen aus der
schweiz
ich habe den brief okaz hofer bekommen
dass nach männern gekommen und wirklich
das war ein schritt und es war der
schritt der uns nach vorne gebracht hat
also marianne problem mit der maschine
mit energie natürlich hatten sie mit der
marktstellung café bazar und mit peter
buhl wo die buddelei natürlich probiert
ihre mädels strecke mit wasser oder
andere zutaten und mich enden
unter anderem für das hier könne der fed
kalte der welt bestimmt selber andere
dass das haben wir dort im labor
ich führte und die leute gelernt und
marian als mitglieder hand kaum negativ
uhr trotz cool das ist auch für mich
selber ob es schön wenn ich die
erfahrung gemacht hat in der langen
berufsleben sinnvoll irgendwo bitte gebt
uns unsere prozesse nochmals
kontrolliert und richtiggestellt viel
und gebastelt bei den geräten und auch
bei temperaturen und mich alles im griff
bekommen
so hatten wir in zwei wochen ganz neue
qualitätsprodukte
[Musik]
kukksi wie sie der betrieb aufbauen
messe und trotz allen problem ist dass
eben anbieter gang die spiele starten
trotz allem menschlich die so
interessant dass an ihre sportler
verloren in rumänien ex hippie dass
marian in der schweiz hierhin nieder
könige dem tor fliegt
marianna lin genießt die nähe zur
belegschaft
es macht sie stolz zu sehen dass frauen
in ihrem eigenen dorf in einem modernen
betrieb mit fairen arbeitsbedingungen
beschäftigt sind
dennoch hat sie die
anfangsschwierigkeiten mit denen sie als
junge unternehmerin zu kämpfen hatte
nicht vergessen in einem land in dem
korruption und amtsmissbrauch noch immer
zum alltag gehören
vor 16 jahren war ich schon sehr junge
frau ich kann mich erinnern zum
veterinäramt gegangen mit meiner planung
und die leute stand sein großer direktor
so und das wird kommen wenn du mit
seinen großen stapel papier kommt dann
können wir dann das kann er vergessen
wenn ich denke an den anfang es macht
wirklich harte zeiten aber seitdem wir
uns stabilisiert haben mit dem geschäft
dann habe ich das nicht mehr
[Musik]
auch edin dacic holte sich unterstützung
aus der schweiz als es darum ging die
produktivität seiner fabrik zu steigern
und somit auch konkurrenzfähig zu werden
der größte wendepunkte ziehen wo wir ein
berater von der swiss kontakt treten und
die hände
sino export kol das sind pensioniert die
experten sicher den antrag stellt nach
weniger als 48 stunden die mailbox
da kam mit genau dem profil und peter
foley mal so heißt experte ich grüße sie
anfang 2005 und hätte fragen was willst
du genau vor mir die stelle daher die
macher bisher hände die größte firma vor
der welt als partner gefährlich gemacht
und ich kann dem sandloch ich will dass
du vergisst dass du in box nämlich stell
dir vor da staut da alles in die schweiz
[Applaus]
nach drei monaten wurde dort verbracht
hat und alles autorität analysiert und
so weiter
die schweiz will muss doch hersteller
dass wir wachsen und dass der umsätze
richten der nächste schritt sind die
belegschaft glaubte jedoch eher die
nazis nicht dass der arbeitgeber für die
angestrebte produktionssteigerung auch
den versprochenen doppelten lohn
auszahlt ich vertraue da und das thema
machen denn die zwei monaten ihr stelle
zu verstopfen
und wenn mir eine doppelte zahl den
höchsten bezirksliga hat wenn man
dominieren und den themen wie
alternative zu der alten nach weniger
als zwei monaten mehr als doppelt so
viele gekommen
gestoßen als großes handicap
wie gut dass du das mit dem xf brachte
ich kann über wenn das letzte an einer
jahres zusammen liegt es kontakte sei
dass die operationen ja total blöd nur
eine frau kann ganz kaputt aber vor
allem im osten eher gering ist die
allerbeste chris vorrangig mit nützlich
sie die mini fabrikations technik und
was ganz wichtig ich sehe aber zurzeit
studiert sieht studie
jeder arbeitsplatz ist die arbeit a lot
of work st also nicht es geht nicht
darum schnell wirtschaft der vom
arbeiter sondern wirklich so zu andere
ich sehe dass der hedge fonds oder den
vornamen wie viel freiraum cloud also ja
vorstellig k mögliche kaka netz auch
verständlich sie nie aber sie machen
erwirken und forum k
ja man sich zeit baute rädelsführer
kassel tätig also einfach feststellen
nach ex jugoslawien hobby haben die ganz
viel arbeit ich sehe wo die panik vor
technisch technik als beispiel
die handscanner machen wo man könne
irgendwie damit schaffen wenn ich
intelligenz ist die ausbildung und mit
heidi
[Musik]
dacic stellte früh fest dass für
mittlere und höhere kader im land
qualifizierte fachleute fehlen
diesem mangel an fachkräften wollte er
mit einer idee entgegen wirken die sich
bewährt hat
in münster ist willig system implodiert
ist entweder hinter wirtschaft die um
ständig abschlüsse oder sind sie ab
schloss aber nicht schlimm die schweiz
hat soviel wüster zur verfügung wo sie
wird gern teilen das puma phone nutzer
und so habe ich falsch identifiziert
die sind förderungswürdig dort in ein
paar jahren die musiker die entwickler
dass sie höhere positionen kabine und
durch meine kontakte früherer kann ich
sehr gut wirklich vor der fachhochschule
in biel sehr gut kennt und habe ich ihm
das verzeihen und heck sei klug mehr und
alles für tierversuche im darauf
folgenden jahr wurde an der
fachhochschule für holz und architektur
in biel ein einjähriger lehrgang
entwickelt maßgeschneidert für das
mittlere kader der holzwirtschaft in
bosnien
das modular aufgebaute training findet
teils in bosnien und teils hier in biel
statt mit finanziert wird das projekt
von der deetzer der direktion für
entwicklung und zusammenarbeit haben
insgesamt etwa 60 mittlere kader aus der
holzwirtschaft in bosnien ausgebildet
diese leute sind zentral in den
betrieben weil sie diesen link zwischen
produktion und topmanagement machen
können und das ist oft ein großes
problem dort weil es keine
fachhochschulen gibt die wirklich diesen
praxisbezug vermitteln können
das heißt sieht gibt so diese lücke die
wir mit diesem projekt versuchen zu
schließen
wir werden ein experiment machen eine
tür wird von der sonne angestrahlt das
hier ist unsere tür ein ganz normales
türblatt
dahinter haben wir infrarot lampen wie
für die sonne stehen diese lampen sind
ziemlich stark sie werden hitze auf der
oberfläche der tür erzeugen und wir
werden uns anschauen wie stark sie sich
verbiegt
wir werden die sonne für eine halbe
stunde scheinen lassen
aber damit es spannend bleibt habt ihr
nun die aufgabe zu schätzen wie stark
die verbiegung sein wird jeder von euch
gibt eine schätzung ab und schreibt
seinen namen hierhin es ist ein fünf
sterne direktion der schule dass wir
solche projekte machen mit schwellen-
und entwicklungsländer
wir haben hier viel infrastruktur mit
labor mit maschinen prüflabor können
viele arten von testern machen mit holz
mit produkte jetzt beginnt die sonne zu
scheinen
ihr merkt die sind ganz schön heiß
[Musik]
also lassen wir sie ein wenig scheinen
und wir gehen darüber
hier haben sehr viele praktische
beispiele aus der betrieben die wir in
den vorlesungen in der kurzen praktische
übungen benutzen können
und das ist glaube ich auch einen großen
mehrwert für sie wenn sie hier in der
schweiz kommen
jetzt ist es an der zeit zu messen wie
stark die biegung ist genau so wie ihr
es vorhin gemacht habe
die politik
388 zeigt mal ob du nachrechnen kannst
und jetzt schauen wir auf die liste wer
ist am nächsten dran
[Applaus]
gute schweizer schokolade und wer ist
der zweite
movie modus könnt ihr die drei dinge auf
listen die euch am meisten beeindruckt
haben was werden die firmenbesuche die
wir hatten
sie haben uns dort gezeigt wie sie
arbeiten und wie sieht es das können wir
in der schule nicht lernen bei uns
überwiegt die theorie hier ist auch der
praxis antrag hoch die dozenten sind
zugänglicher und offen der abstand
zwischen dozierenden und studierenden
ist hier geringer die schweizer
entwickeln praxis und theorie parallel
weiter sie reagieren auf
marktbedürfnisse es ist faszinierend es
ist alles software basiert sie haben
barcode leser an jeder maschine
ich finde dieses wissens transfer sehr
spannend und sehr wichtig weil wir in
der schweiz so innovativ sind und können
sehr viel einfacher transferieren in
länder wo leute keinen zugang zu diesem
namen haben
b
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
maria anna leenen setzt in ihrem
unternehmen schon früh auf
nachhaltigkeit
die kunden schätzen die qualität ihrer
produkte in einer zeit wo überall
billigware angeboten wird sie konnte
ihre produkte in den warenhäusern nicht
so präsentieren wie sie es wollte was
sie schließlich motiviert hat eigene
verkaufs geschäfte zu eröffnen
ich habe selber verkauft auch im
geschäft und was dir das jahr ein neues
geschäft aber mit geöffnet mit der
meisten geschäft haben uns auch besser
gekannte kunden und wir haben auch vom
kundschaft fast alle kindergärten aus
der stadt wir haben die krankenhäuser
altersheime
was mich freut ist dass viele kinder
raten ärzte für die kinder unserer
produkte empfehlen wir aber noch weiße
produkte keine zusätze keine früchte die
man gar nicht sein um seiner zielgruppe
von kunden es sind schon die leute die
ernährungs wertlos sind
als ich in der schweiz gelebt habe wir
sind sie auch nach italien gegangen
und das war dann wieder fest in italien
und habe immer gedacht so waren mit
gedankenkraft zu haben ein eigenes café
zu haben aber das warten wie ganz weit
weg ab es war ein gedanke hinter dem
hinterkopf und so haben wir jetzt einige
cafés
[Musik]
auch einem weiteren wichtigen standbein
des unternehmens der confiserie liegt
eine erfahrung aus dem ausland zu grunde
ich habe mir immer gewünscht
in meiner stadt einen guten kuchen zu
essen
und ob ich meine schwester gesprochen
sie war damals in deutschland und ich
habe gesagt wird dass du nie gern
bleiben dann kochen macht und macht
bietet das gleiche was sie für die
produkte gemacht dabei vielleicht magst
du das für kuchen
so könnten wäre das geschäft entwickelte
sich 2000 seine nase bio gekommen und
wir haben eine kleine grafik geöffnet
und haben wir mit der produktion von
torten und kuchen angefangen inzwischen
ist die confiserie gut gediehen und zu
einer bekannten adresse in sibiu
geworden dass wirtschaftliche angriff zu
haben so dass man keine verluste für
rohstoffe hat dass man sich die
produktionskosten unser
buchhaltungssystem habe ich so oft
gebaut dass sie nicht im moment weiß im
wäldchen geschäft einkauft verkauft hat
die die bestände die wir dann
automatisch angepasst und es stimmte
alles
ich wollte selbstständig arbeiten und
ich wollte dass mein mann machen
ich habe sehr viel gelernt in der
schweiz und ihr wollte einfach etwas mit
den händen machen etwas produzieren und
sie macht das gerne gemacht sind der
morgenarbeit danach in der confiserie im
man in dem geschäft dann auch und so
außerhalb von unser motto ist blinder
parteien europäische mandate das heißt
auf deutsch voll dabei zu sein nicht die
hälfte
gut ausgebildetes personal zu finden es
dem jungen eu land rumänien nicht
einfach weil die leute lieber im ausland
arbeiten wollen wo sie besser verdienen
auch marianna klagt über die große
fluktuation in ihrem unternehmen
dann findet sich dann ein vertrag in
england oder in deutschland und sie
wandern aus wir können mit einem
deutschen mann mit einem schweizer
gehalt haltern
trotz unserer bezahlung die
überdurchschnittlich ist für unser
mitarbeiter
[Musik]
das dynamische junge leute das land
verlassen ist ein problem der ganzen
region
bosnien ist seit jahrzehnten ein
auswanderungsland fast jeder dritte
bosnier lebt im ausland und schickt
regelmäßig geld zur familie in die
heimat
dort wird dieses geld oft in immobilien
oder in lebenskosten investiert somit
dient es zwar dem individuellen haushalt
aber nicht der nachhaltigen entwicklung
des landes der erste grund ist die
finanzielle situation
die leute finden hier keinen job der
ihre existenz sichert der zweite grund
ist dass sie in bosnien keine sichere
zukunft für sich sehen deshalb wollen
sie auswandern um in anderen ländern
arbeit zu finden
es ist traurig für ein land wenn die
jungen leute weg gehen denn das land hat
in sie investiert und sie ausgebildet
sie gingen hier zur schule zur
universität
aber wenn die zeit kommt dass sie etwas
zurückgeben könnten indem sie hier
arbeiten und dem land nützlich sind
gehen sie weg das ist für das land eine
katastrophe
es herrscht perspektivlosigkeit
das ist die größte gefahr und ein
augenlid land fordert es gibt viele
legen jetzt aber ein riesiger gegensatz
zwischen ganze region vom balkan und der
schweiz deutschland sagen die entwickler
der westeuropäische länder und zwar
jedes schweiz herrscht der privaten
wirtschaft niederländer in der luft
unterwegs ist es genau das gegenteil
mehr wirtschaft sind dazu dort von der
politik die eine und klassische
verhängnis das muss sich ändern und so
langsam tastet wird ändere wird kreis
von der leyen deutlich dass jedes volle
wirtschaftliche potenzial und schöpferin
der unternehmer den touch nutzt seine
einflussreiche position um sich in die
politik des landes einzumischen er ist
den wichtigen unternehmensverbänden
aktiv tritt fiel auf und seine meinung
ist gefragt
ich begleite ihn zu einem treffen von
wirtschaftsleuten mit
regierungsvertretern in der residenz der
schweizer botschaft in sarajevo
jetzt mittelland und herzlich willkommen
zum swiss business land die absicht
hinter diesen versammlungen ist mit euch
in kontakt zu bleiben aber auch laufende
themen mit euch zu besprechen die von
belang sind für unsere schweizer
investoren in bosnien und herzegowina
und um das networking unter euch zu
fördern
dacic spricht offen aus was er im land
bemängelt an diesem treffen geräte mit
regierungsvertretern in eine heiße
diskussion über die zu hohen
staatsausgaben
sie müssen verstehen dass wir aufgrund
der situation in bosnien keine
steuerausfälle in kauf nehmen können
dadurch würde das staatsbudget leiden
wir hoffen dass die katastrophale
diskrepanz zwischen dem öffentlichen und
dem privatsektor aufgerufen
ich bin nicht einverstanden lassen sie
mich reden über die löhne im
öffentlichen sektor sprechen
in der föderation ist es fast das
doppelte glaube lassen sie mich noch
etwas anfügen können sie ein anderes
land nennen in dem 60 bis 70 prozent des
bruttosozialprodukts für
staatsverwaltung verwendet werden
nur ein land
[Musik]
die staatliche viel zu tür und geht viel
zu wenig die gesellschaft kruck und
folter vor
im endeffekt hat sich eine lange kette
aber folgte wo ich das nettolöhne vor
der ab stellte im privatsektor zu
niedrig sind bisher geerntet wenn wir
den fans viel sympathie verblieb aber
ich bin viel antipathie dass der reform
nicht schneller ungefährdet nicht mehr
richtig förderung von der wirtschaft
[Musik]
sogar mein schatz wie geht's dir was
machst du da ist das dein helikopter
weißt du welches buch ich gerade lese
nein was liest du denn ich komme gleich
zurück das buch das gib mir mal kurz mal
[Musik]
schmerzt dass man immer so groß ist
freut wenn du mir das zurückkommen dafür
ist der preis bezahlen wenn der job hält
der mit vielen reisetätigkeit verbunden
ist ich wollte den emotionalen zum
familienvan zum kind gott wenn zum
ungerechtigkeit gott wenn nicht so viel
man will mehr
beide hof finde dann kann ich sehr
emotional werden dass ein großteil vom
energie zu mini emotionen unter
kontrolle hat
dacic ist bekannt aus guter netzwerker
sein wirken ist breit und sichtbar
so ist er zum beispiel aktiv im verein
ii diaz bauer der sich von der schweiz
aus für die entwicklung von bosnien und
herzegowina einsetzt auf seine
initiative hin war bosnien im jahr 2018
bastlern deiner großen tourismusmessen
in der schweiz
er ist überzeugt dass sein wissen und
seine verbindungen auch anderen türen
öffnen können
ich weiß dass sie die alice muster
www.michael metallgitter fahrige oder
für lehrte kontakte knüpfen
und ich lernte sehr finde wie oft ich so
dass man solche sachen wo man immer
macht wird man deswegen betriebsblind
und richtig dass immer sehr gut wie in
einer holding wenn ich es anders machen
wenn es mit lehrerschaft zu erhalten
anders besen ist ein anderer branchen zu
vita ich genieße das exzellenten die
kleine mobile office wo denn wie ich
wiederum kraft für mich eigene projekte
adli
wollen das einfach erzählen ganz schnell
vorbei
seine kindheit und jugend verbrachte er
den dacic hier in kreuzlingen eine zeit
in der ihnen die identitätsfrage
allerdings sehr stark beschäftigte mit
dem geist so geworden
das jugoslawien meine heimat ist dass
mir nur für der bayern spitze sind und
dass das episode wie ich dir wird
relativ rasch vorüber
den ist ein aufmerksamer so ist egal wo
er geht geschäftliche tokio wenn er
ankommt versteht mir immer eine sms
und so weiß immer wo er ist und wie es
ihm geht und haben wir die aussage ruhig
er war sehr ambitionierte war superschön
supersportler der herr war gut so und
jetzt als geschäftsmann hat sich sehr
sehr gut gewesen und war mit welchem
stolz und bin ich so froh dass er zwei
größere kinder aus dem vorübergehenden
aufenthalt in der schweiz sind
inzwischen 45 jahre geworden dienst
mutter starb vor 13 jahren an krebs
sein vater lebt mit seiner neuen
partnerin christina zusammen die auch in
der zahnarztpraxis mitarbeitet in die
nationale identität kann ich nicht
geografisch lokalisieren
dass ich fragte mich früher noch extrem
beschäftigt hat bis sich so nennt seine
meine technik sowie aber alles mit dem
auseinanderfallen jugoslawiens hat sich
die frage für mich hätten nehme gestellt
ich bitte mir bewusst wurde dass ich mir
meine eigene identität schaffen muss das
ist hier nicht darf fest machen welche
länder start der nationen religionen
für mich sind das kriterium kategorien
den ich denke
[Musik]
nein
ich hab gewusst dass es laufen lässt und
immer wieder immer wieder probiert
zentrale probleme und immer lösungen
gesucht
ich lasse mich nicht unter druck und
wenn ich was fehlt und ich bekomme es
auch aber habe auf ihn gearbeitet
[Musik]
kaum saubergemacht 16 jahren die die
leute mich schon als die leute aus dem
geschäftsumfeld kenne mich ich bin
korrekt unter das wort ist ein bot ein
mann
eine frau beantwortet
[Musik]
ganz familie tage die gottes von lewis
für 40 geburtstag
louis und nüsse
ich bin voll dann ist stets rücken
zurück in das funktional zu stehen so
meine batterien mit auflagen versehen
gegen den trend ein vorbild für meine
freunde und meine familie und das gibt
wieder neue energie zum wittmann
[Musik]
[Applaus]